finally soccer is good for something I
kid I love soccer
here's Israel Prime Minister
congratulating Iran on their exploits in
something called the World Cup
apparently the World Cup is a
competition between countries that play
soccer it's very popular around the
world can you imagine how hard it is to
stop Ronaldo from scoring the goal I
used to play soccer let me tell you it's
almost impossible but the Iranian team
just did the impossible to the Iranian
people I say you showed courage on the
playing field and today you show the
same courage in the streets of Iran
that's why I offered medical aid to save
Iranian lives after a devastating
earthquake one day I'll hope to watch
Iran's soccer team go head-to-head
against Israel in a free Tehran on that
day we'll all be winners
so as we worry about incivility within
our own borders we're watching olive
branches sprouting from all over
somewhat similar to Trump's North Korea
experiment Netanyahu is taking out we'll
see what happens approach to Iran trying
to lower the temperature by appealing to
similar human needs and desires we all
like soccer and watching soccer with our
families and you can only really do that
when there's peace and prosperity now
Yahoo's creating a contrast between what
is and what could be does that sound
familiar as john bolton and his
moustache meets with putin there seems
to be a new pattern taking shape and
while world leaders have exchanged
pleasantries before this feels different
it's as if peace is being sold and
finally people are buying let's hope
these opportunities aren't squandered
the way they were before so if an
outstretched hand works with North Korea
which can go either way at this point or
Iran or Russia maybe it can work with
our fellow Americans too to quote the
guy you kick to kick this whole thing
off
we'll see what happens all right there's
a couple of things here he's appealing
to what's going on in Iran right now the
streets of Iran the people are out on
the street they're out there having a
lot of protests because we put our
sanctions back on it started to have an
immediate effect because sanctions are
effective unlike before however and I
would just say way back these protests
in this week they are in the streets are
shouting death
to the Palestinians not death to the
United States they are focused on their
government as being the enemy of the
people of Iran that is provides a big
opening and I imagine that Netanyahu
their Intel is great so they're figuring
out if you can talk directly to the
people of Iran they might be able to
force change in their leadership the
other thing I would say is that the
freedom of information being able to get
unfiltered raw information through
people's phones on the Internet rather
than through state television could be a
really big answer in Iran Venezuela
other places maybe even North Korea and
Russia frankly Jesse I'm a little
worried about what's going on in North
Korea now have you been following that
stuff there's that there was some detail
at some some I guess showing that they
might have started new work on a nuclear
facility yeah I mean it's troubling I
think that Trump needs to re-engage on
that and I'm sure he will get the stick
right keep the momentum going on that
maybe he needs to play around the golf
with kim jeong-hoon or you know I think
obviously Sports is an elixir remember
the spirit around the country during the
Olympics yes that's always positive and
you saw what happened with North and
South Korea on that front and what Trump
plays golf with people I think that only
placated worms you know placate the the
Lord leaders North Korea I was kidding
about the round of golf maybe Laura Lago
they might go for you know around 18 who
knows but in all seriousness Hank I
think he I think people are moving away
from isolationism to a certain extent
into a new era of engagement it's just
interesting that Donald Trump is a
Netanyahu are the ones leading that
charge yeah why don't you think that
there could be a summit in the offing if
the u.s. and North Korea can do it why
not Israel in Iran I don't see that
coming
[Laughter]
but I must say I was awed by the way you
put icing or pink eyeglasses on to talk
about what's going on in North Korea
okay maybe you could do that too with
harley-davidson moving out it was a
result of Trump's tear go ahead and try
but I mean it's unbelievable I mean if
this was Obama you guys would be
celebrate oh look at North Korea's out
there doing their own thing but we
wouldn't be celebrating
point is it needs to be addressed it
needs to push back on him and maybe it's
time for some more fire and fury not
golf or chocolate
tomorrow Lago although that would be
nice but I mean he's got he's not gonna
put up with it that's for sure so if kim
jeong-hoon wants to you know play you
know cutesy with President Trump but you
think again you'll lose that battle by
the way I do enjoy soccer I just don't
enjoy watching it I love playing it it's
fun to play but it's not enough scoring
for me I guess America is not in it this
year so it's a lot of running around a
lot of running around and I don't like
running around I like people to bring
the ball to me